hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
genetic recombination and bacteria
bacterial cells have this really cool
ability to obtain extra DNA through
various mechanisms that can give them
extra functionality what this means is
they can pull DNA from different places
using a few different mechanisms and the
DNA may enable them to be resistant to
some type of antibiotic it may enable
them to gain a virulent factor so
something that allows them to establish
or maintain an infection of a host or it
can give them the ability to couse
toxins these are all examples of ways
that bacteria can benefit from genetic
recombination the three types of genetic
recombination are called transformation
conjugation and transduction I have
videos on all three of these types so
you can check those out in this video we
are talking about conjugation
conjugation is made possible by a
plasmid that is extra chromosomal DNA so
what this means is it is circular DNA
that is separate from the actual
bacterias chromosomal DNA in particular
this plasmid is called
a conjugated plasmid you might also hear
it referred to as a fertility
the reason that this plasmid makes
conjugation possible is because in
addition to any other genes that it may
encode so genes for antibiotic
resistance for a virulence factor it
also encodes genes for something called
a sex Phyllis and it is this sex palace
which enables conjugation to happen the
actual definition of conjugation is the
transfer of genetic material from one
bacterial cell to another bacterial cell
by direct cell to cell contact that
direct cell to cell contact is made
possible by the sex LS for example if
you have a bacteria here that has this
conjugative or fertility plasmid this is
called an f-plus cell with fertility
plasmid encodes genes for effects fellas
this is basically a cellular structure
that allows the f+ valve to connect with
an f-minus cell so a cell that does not
already have this classman then the
conjugated plasmid is able to transfer a
copy of itself from the f+ fell to the
f- cell in a process of conjugation now
that we have talked about the basics of
conjugation let's look at the mechanism
and a little bit more detail here we
start with our F plus cell that has the
fertility class names here drawn in red
and then s minus L which lacks with
agility plasmids both of these cells
have chromosomal DNA as well
and remember that the fertility plasmid
codes for the sex
LS it is the sex palace that enabled the
direct cell to cell contact needed for
conjugation to occur here we have our F
plus cell which is our donor cell it
contains this fertility plasma that is
capable of replicating itself and then
the copy of a fertility plasmid goes
through the sex palace and enters the
recipient cell's cytoplasm the result of
this is you have our original f plus
cell it still has its fertility plasmid
but now that recipient cell has a copy
of the fertility cotton as well so now
it is also considered an F plus L so it
is capable of repeating this process
which is one of the possibilities that
may occur next where you get this newly
made positive cell basically starting
this process over again
also remember that the fertility plasma
contains not only the DNA necessary to
make the sex fellas
it also can contain other genes that can
give the cells something something
different in it and happy for other
genes required to help them survive an
unfriendly environment genes that confer
resistance to some sort of antibiotic so
for exists for example this new at plug
valve now that is gained this plasmid it
might be resistant to streptomycin which
means that it's infecting a human host
streptomycin is no longer going to work
to be able to share that infection so in
addition to this possibility of this
cell continuing to share these genes
with other at- cells through the process
of conjugation something else can happen
as well that's drawn here this is when
we have
chromosomal DNA it has actually allowed
the fertility plasmid DNA to integrate
into the chromosome so if the fertility
partment
integrate in the bacterial chromosome so
now we have one unit of DNA this cell is
called an H F our cell hf r stands for
high frequency of recombination these
cells are capable of doing something
interesting where they still have this
DNA from the original fertility positive
so they can still form FX Phillips to
connect from the HR cell which we will
draw is newly integrated chromosome this
X plus allows the age of our cell to
connect to an F - cell this F minus L
I've drawn its chromosomal DNA and blue
simply so we can distinguish between the
original chromosomal DNA of this valve
and black the fertility plasmid DNA
that's still in red as it's been
throughout and then the chromosomal DNA
of this new recipient at - cell what
happens at this point is the fertility
plasmid DNA replicate so that the DNA
from both the red DNA the fertility
plasmid DNA as well as the chromosomal
DNA Francis aja our cell is able to copy
itself and then move in - yep - cell
what we get at this point the result is
we still have this HFR cell that has its
chromosomal DNA and then the integrative
fertility plasmid DNA but we also have
this at - cell has undergone
recombination between its original
chromosome
and some of the chromosomal DNA that it
got from the HFR cell what this looks
like is it still has its original
chromosomal DNA and blue but it's picked
up some of the chromosomal DNA it was
copied from the HFR cell it came through
sex tell us what we get here is a
recombinant cell it's still enough -
cell it doesn't have any of this red DNA
that came from the fertility - but it
still has acquired extra genes which
means that if this cell has any kind of
extra DNA already incorporated into its
chromosome originally it's now been
integrated into the chromosome of this F
- cell again this means that that might
have cell while it's not capable of
further conjugation on its own it's
missing utility plasmid DNA it still may
have acquired additional functionality
in the hormone virulence factors or
antibiotic resistance or toxins that it
can now produce simply because it's
gained this extra DNA so this is how the
process of conjugation works to give
bacterial cells these additional genes